your news was great news yeah not bad
news and it's official and it's a girl
gigi hadid is expecting her first child
she confirmed the news to Jimmy Fallon
in a video chat on Thursday and I gotta
say congratulations on expecting a baby
it's the best news we're very excited
and and happy and grateful for
everyone's support so the revelation
comes after et reported on Tuesday that
Gigi was 20 weeks pregnant with
boyfriend zayn malik of course i mean i
i feel i met him in person once before
he's obviously so gorgeous but really
the way that we could have conversations
and kind of just were really interested
in the same things and it was really
easy the couple's relationship status
has been in flux in 2015 with their
romance rekindling again at some point
within the last few months they're
currently quarantined together with GG's
family like especially during this time
it's nice it's a nice silver lining
people to like be home and together and
like really experience it day by day
Gigi also revealed to Jimmy the special
gift she received for her birthday last
week that was inspired by her current
pregnancy craving in the morning my
family brought out everything bagel cake
which already blew my mind because my
craving has been everything bagels I eat
it everything bagel a day and so I was
already like so excited that my birthday
cake was everything bagel but then I
found out that buddy the Cake Boss made
my cake wait that was a cake yes we know
mama Hadid probably doesn't mind having
Zayn around in 2017 Yolanda told et what
she admired about the former One
Direction member he's just a really good
person you know he comes from very
humble beginnings so he's just
normal guy and he's he's a good human
being
[Music]